[Musica]
mi sono mancate
giunto il momento di appropriarsi
indebitamente del canale di willwoosh di
esporsi mediaticamente
chiedi come un feticista sul canale da
oltre 1 milioni distretti come
vi trovate sadico ma
sapete non c'è niente di sadico e quello
che faccio
adesso solo proprio
all'apice del mio masochista
[Musica]
ed
eccomi qua ma l'hai portato il caffè
questa mattina certo tutto è importante
però messa io non è finita ancora tu
orario lavorativo di nonna allora vuoi
il caffè perché non posso né caramia
tesoro mio che ha detto che non ci puoi
andare solo arrivo posta in camera mia
ma in fila del questa juve regionale dei
cristiani ad acri
dove vedere in giro che oggi sono
deboluccia tra l'altro posizione lo
saprò manciata di merda dopo in
inghilterra e quindi ti devi rifare un
pochino e che cosa vuoi mangiare dirlo
[Musica]
dove dobbiamo andare fieri e vico
nonna 47 abbiamo borsa chi rimane la
vaniglia in mano è certo tesoro le balle
tutte in mano qualcosa e nonna noi
ascolta così non capisco proprio io sono
confusa ma la cazzo di giungla ma che
cosa è successo è di mode e io non ci
sono stato due mesi
schumann attenta che casca tutto qua
[Risate]
[Musica]
svegliati bambino
[Risate]
organizzato da islam posso diritti
[Musica]
diamo praticamente organizzato un pranzo
da islam un amico fraterno stanno così e
se come dopo l'ultima volta dubito che
cui che vorrà ecco che
entra in gioco tutto che devo fare la
lite
è stata convocata apposta il numero uscì
giammarco
guglielmo buongiorno
che stai facendo invece in realtà avrei
urgenza di parlarti di una cosa
importante di lavoro
è grave no no no no è una cosa molto non
grave ma molto importante ci teniamo a
parlartene a stretto giro insomma ti do
un appuntamento nolo entra un'ora ti
mando la posizione
sì sì tutto posto
va benissimo tranquillo ti sto per
condividere subito la posizione
ok no no no tranquillo non c'è nessun
problema
a dopo
avvocato ottimo debutto punta fa
che cazzo ma fornacella c'è una riga
testate forza
mamma mia è un gabinetto questa macchina
ci sono ancora i vetri di gwen dove
l'hanno sfondata avere di esposizione
mediatica per le cosce de oro natale
concedeva queste l'orecchino di 10 dic
in
esposizione sino esposizione mediatica
per bucce di banana giovani che schifo
che fate loro no
e poi c'è poi mangiare una banana e ora
una banana non so parole ti stavi
facendo confronto è sbagliato stato di
mandare dall'islam ma chi è islam
buongiorno ma c'è islam
solo gabriele
la verità sto arrivando con acqua guarda
in tempo reale se noi invochiamo da qua
blocchiamo qua ma anche di colori per i
quali non crediamo li l'oncia di altro
pezzo di merda vedi come ti inchiodo
[Musica]
ecco nelle guide ha sì sì sì sì l'ho
visto
domani prende
per la liberta di fermo 4 pc
scusa
se state pregato e yelp e noi andiamo a
parlare di lavoro guglielmo io pisciate
una persona a pranzo ma è appropriazione
indebita
orniello più importante dei gusti non
c'è nulla aver portato
corro state o 20 sale sul pianeta tonno
rosso entrambi vado parcheggiamo anche
la isla ma c'è sempre corso piccolo
passo in avanti hanno canadian così
proprio non segreto non becca la
macchina seconda dei cassonetti ma ci
siamo in mezzo alla strada siamo da
islam esposizione mediatica per il
siciliano p le posizioni mediatica per
l'islam e qui hanno avvicinati a isla
eccoci eccoci
ecco basta la mano in vaticano c'è il
papa ecco c'è islam stavolta siamo amici
ed a tardo esposizioni mediatiche a
verità
allora la conoscete paola di san carlo
guardate la leggenda il maestro la
macchina una lista che lo so ma the road
alcuno
siete bevi 3 bottiglia di vino mattina
volte il velino più mal di testa devi
ringraziare dentro
quasi massiccia con altro come di che
percorso che c'è la dieta sbagliata
a casa porta chiusa mai
franciacorta biologico superiore
franciacorta biologico salentino
superiore biologico
permesso permesso sta passando islam ha
permesso permesso fate spazio
islam
siccome è un appropriazione indebita di
che l'ho già scusa per quello che
potrebbe succedere anzi riformano che
succederà ti faccio vedere subito è qui
fa quando il prodotto
il nostro non sono anche
chiusa ma che cos'è questa cosa questo è
il prodotto perfetto
eventi mentore di
matera ti mando al san paolo io mi sto
vergognando islam possiamo far portare
un po di kourou di maurizio amico mio mi
presento maurizio il cuoco siciliano
nostro compaesano numero uno maurizio
adesso il piacere ti chiedo scusa per il
mio fratello eccolo eccolo di santa
paola di san carlo paola di san carlo
quando scoprire venire anche questo
tavolo
paola design paura di san carlo paura di
giancarlo pola di san carlo ma basta che
per paura di cercarlo io me lo sogno
strike e comodi che cosa tre cose che ci
sarebbe bene tartare di tonno a tappeto
che il tavolo tartare di spigola e vuole
di pure salmone ananas che sgrassa il
contrasto perché no ma questo va a
mangiare un certo modo lo stamani a male
non sai come si fa gambero puntate olio
di islam a questa nazionale
un nonnulla di sale punta di pepe vai
pepe
direbbe che vede islam
veit
all
no
le tue mani a mente ma sbaglio o quella
e paola di san carlo ma una di san carlo
capiti a fagiolo stato quello che è
paola perché aveva un'ossessione bravo
paolo brava paola paola di san carlo
come razionalità e sbagliato un'altra
volta un cazzo non si sbaglia un'altra
volta quetta questa acquistate troppo
via erodiani in franciacorta prende il
franciacorta ci vogliono le bollicine
per niente forchettina l'ha svuotata
da cacare maschi fa è veramente fare
altrimenti che qualcuno ahi ahi non
perde nei fatti accompagnare dalla vita
infatti al compagno nella vita come dici
i
soliti accompagna e mortificata
eccolo
scampo affacciato ma guardandola
riguardano la
cosa
se sono imbarazzate beh diciamo cambiato
maiolo nota sara questo fa schifo
nessuno sembra uscito dalla doccia fatto
male al dito
che schifo
[Musica]
ice e trattorie quelle che ti porti di
gatti cordino xi e trattorie più serie
che esistono ti portano la zuppa con
link a strada dedito perché l'ora da una
somma condito si vuole senza
fiato
facondino
eccellente più orrore mamma e che orrore
solo l'inizio che orrore mordi
voglio dire una cosa esistono due
categorie di persone al mondo chi passa
anche il piatto al cameriere e che non
gli passa il più attacchi a vedere tassa
piatta al cameriere una persona migliore
una che si accorge degli altri e io ti
dico una cosa paola di san carlo
chi fa sul piatto
facendo così alzare ieri
stai uscendo con una massima la stabile
scusate ma quelli che i vostri piatti è
arrivata a terra spesso tartara anch'io
ceyhan che va da farsi e questo vi
meritate islam fa che dovremmo fare
stavolo a parte se ancora aspetta che
allontano
da
lontano dalla mia vista
posso passarti il piatto
ti passo passo tra i
piacciono sera isla ma io dico proprio
scacco matto scacco di scoperta
scacco di scoperta e quindi ma la
regista e il suo cazzo
a parolo gianmarco la prossima volta
però che dobbiamo fare cose mi devi dire
né che arrivò cioè il pazzo islam
guarda io sapevo niente quanto idee moda
passiamo a vende così mangiare ma tu sei
pazzo vi faccio vedere equilibri non
c'erano 30 d'olio di isla
uno nulla di sale punta di neve pezzo di
insalata dentro
che t'ha fatto
la mamma mia
il siciliano
fiscale facevano se vuoi
perché aveva faccio il messaggio
promozionale il comico siciliano pesci
tartare di tonno estranei se volete
un'alternativa al sesso venite al
siciliano fashion
paese dove vanno le patatine le patatine
giancarlo io chiamo capito gabriele
gabriele tra persone che pensa essere
simpatico con i dati in maniera salle
chiodi gabenelli di odia e chi odia
indiana e ti odia
[Risate]
[Applauso]
dimostrarlo con un'altra borsa di vino
all'orizzonte
un board che bere ma guarda che bella
camicia nera ma trovi che sia una bella
capigliatura
una camicia da padre di famiglia per
diventare padre sta per diventare ma
possiamo dire anzi a tutte quante le
persone che hanno carrozzine lettini
omogeneizzati aiutate questo futuro
padre
e ci risiamo
allora sì recidivo
ricapitoliamo
le barriere invito scacco di scoperta e
quindi matto
paula elisa carlo e paola di san carlo
io mi faccio il piano la vita
prendilo la prendi con te la prendi il
prezzo prendilo carisma di scuola
sentire st tartare di spigola
[Applauso]
[Risate]
cesar para fritturina stavamo non mi
chiamo fritturina questo motto vorrei
presentare quello che io possa baracca
quadri se la portava avanti a caso non
hai capito ci sposiamo è come i
matrimoni adesso abbiamo una dove sarà
pericolanti passa adesso ci spostiamo
dentro per i primi si condivide con me
come una
bomba
da cinque gradi hanno
regalato continua bagnasco
le posso fidarmi della vecchina del dito
stanno dove se ti fai tu ce l'hai the
poor sulla vita non c'era il male dico
un fasto e orrore il mondo orrori in mod
prese una cattiva influenza per c'entro
io
quando vedi gli devi fare una panoramica
schiaffo pan su islam se esposizione
mediatica bellissima ok eccolo
321 panoramica schiaffo
[Musica]
questa unione
noi prendiamo un altro
dopo avervi portato a questo banchetto
qui a casa di islam vi invito ad entrare
dentro per il proseguo del banchetto a
corte per
i primi a seguire islamista
seguite tutti tipo pifferaio magico
[Risate]
maurizio eccomi qua ei passaggi dei
primi ci penso io l'ho assaggiata alla
famiglia bellavia
alla famiglia quella era
alla famiglia
nasce la viglia della famiglia quella
vera perché
possa dire più di una sorella garanti
per essere nella nostra famiglia
grato ragazzo credo per per aver
accompagnato la plata nostra famiglia
questa tesi
il cagnolino spigole il live di maurito
cosa stavo faccio tipo barbieri
ma sul telefono cazzo sul talento
tipo come se manca questa
[Applauso]
[Musica]
che cosa se no niente presto seguito
alla proposta non parlando ora mira
quindi che dopo a scrivere è stato il
destino a farci incontrare non le devi
instaurare una cosa nella sua testa è
tutta una cosa assurda anche lei pensa
due cose che tu lo stai a fa poca quindi
si sente male sappia per culo oppure
dice mari è così bene quindi lei sta
instaurando il tutto che cosa le gray
interessi che mi dia
diverso venire
l'islam
ma io ribatto
[Risate]
e
pure la spagna
[Musica]
ha tutto il tempo per
che cos'è
con le mani sopra
[Risate]
si
no
[Musica]
suo fratello re
arrivare qualcosa con gli occhi
ap la marina
guarda il rispetto della creatura
proprio questo
non ti ho visto un orario
tu sei arrivato andiamo
bene fai da te ma ti faccio a scaldare
voli dei 72 kg che ci ho paura che mi si
infiamma i tendini e poi magari suo
passo le carte mio
team ha reso il martello di thor basta
basta
grazie di essere stata per noi grazie
mille paola
[Risate]
[Musica]
il clan ragazzi vogliamo ringraziare
islam il siciliano fish per l'ospitalità
perché un grande ammirazione massima
ancora altri no grazie per averci
accolti qui islam seguite islam il
siciliano fiches su instagram se volete
altre appropriazione indebita scrivete
tutti qua sotto lo porto via portò via
che cosa l'ha salutato niente che beh
lasciamo solo il silenzio
mai più io già marca colori
giammarco se lo rifà è finita di licenze
cavo saluta
hai sbagliato strada alla prossima
appropriazione indebita da gabriele si
era già detto è il [ __ ]
si chiama la prossima applicazione
indebita e se non ci dovessimo rivedere
[Musica]